well if it isn't Joe Biden and it isn't
Kevin Newsom it might just be the
crystal lady because Marianne Williamson
everyone remembers her she's back in
she's gonna run and check out a little
bit of this why do you want to be
president I want to be president because
this country needs to make an economic
U-turn and the system that effectuates
and perpetuates that kind of income and
opportunity and equality is not changing
itself it tweaks itself every once in a
while there's some incremental change
but the devastation the ubiquitous
economic Despair and human Devastation
that is produced by this sociopathic
economic system is not changing and it's
not going to change if we continue to
elect the same also all right first off
I just want to say as someone that's
interviewed her her accent is totally
fake and she puts that on when she's
doing interviews and it's gotten much
more it's gotten much more drastic than
it was two years ago I I do have to make
note that when I interviewed her two
years ago and I had a bunch of Democrats
on and I treated them exactly the way I
treat all of my guests I had Yang on I
had tulsion who was a Democrat at the
time Marion Williamson the second the
camera went off
she told me that she thinks that the
base of the left are race are are awful
and evil and mean and that she never
gets hate like that from the right and
she then said to me that she's mostly a
Libertarian she would never say that on
camera she got caught once saying that
on camera when she went on uh Eric
bowling's show I think on Newsmax a
couple years ago so the woman is a
complete fraud and what is with
Democrats and fake accents what is that
Sarah
uh I mean well they they don't have any
principles Dave they don't so they have
sauce yeah exactly that's what I'm
saying they shape-shift into whatever
they think that will get them the you
know buy them the most votes buy them
the most likes so they're just
constantly shaping themselves you
mentioned the hot sauce uh you know you
also got like Kamala Harris putting on
some fake accent when she goes and and
talks in front of uh black people you've
got AOC who does the same thing whenever
she's in New York and she wants to act
like she's Jenny from the Bronx and so
they just they don't have any real
principles they don't have a real
identity and so they they just have to
constantly shape-shift into who they're
in front of
Brendan I think it's Jenny From the
Block is the Block in the Bronx though
she's Jenny From the Block but I think
the block is probably in the Bronx right
yeah I would imagine bronx-ish okay it
reminds me of the time fun fact way back
when when Congressman Byron Donalds was
still running his first election for
congress uh in the general he was going
up against this crazy lady Cindy beignet
who was the Democrat opponent and I
hosted their first debate and I was the
I was the moderator for it
Cindy Byron's is very well spoken man
he's a black conservative he's from
Brooklyn he's had trouble with the law
but he's really turned into a great
thing and taking a second chance taking
advantage of his second opportunity
Cindy during the debate
it was like she was straight from the
hood Straight From the Block she I was
like it was so painful because she
doesn't talk like that and we're all
just we're all looking at each other
while this debate is going on for an
hour she was keeping up this accident I
was like what are you doing they're just
pandering because like Sarah said zero
principles I mean Joe Biden he went to a
black college a Puerto Rican College a
Somalian College I lost track of how
many different colleges yeah yeah he
grew up going to Temple he also went to
the mosque he was in the Puerto Rican
Day Parade he's yeah the guy's been
everywhere it's a miracle if you'd like
more sane takes on our insane World
check out our direct message clips
playlist and if you want to watch more
full episodes of our live round tables
watch our round tables playlist they're
both right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell